they came for the sunshine but
bewildered guests at this Tenerife Hotel
had been confined to their rooms
quarantined as the corona virus spreads
around Europe to fellow tourists from
the region in Italy already battling to
contain the virus develop symptoms and
tested positive they've been isolated in
a hospital
the h10 Costa Adeje used by both tui and
jet to holidays is in lockdown this
morning a letter was slipped under our
door before we woke up that's all we
know it said that we weren't allowed to
leave the room for medical reasons or
something the uncontrolled spread of the
virus within Europe has raised fears of
an imminent pandemic this school in
Cheshire has temporarily closed after
pupils who've been skiing in northern
Italy developed flu-like symptoms other
schools around the country have asked
students and staff recently returned
from the region to stay at home as a
precaution the NHS has issued new advice
for anyone who's been to Italy north of
Pisa it's clear that there is a
significant upswing in cases in Italy
and the Italians and we are expecting
more cases to emerge over the next few
days in general were not advising
changes to advice for travel to Italy
all we're saying is that if people come
back from northern Italy and they
subsequently in the next 14 days get
symptoms we recommend that they self
isolate and then phone one-one-one the
World Health Organization has warned
countries to be ready for the virus
knocking at their door in Iran the
Deputy Health Minister has been
quarantined after developing symptoms
during a news conference doctors fear
many cases are going undetected in
Europe the EU says no member nations
have yet considered border closures and
this expert told me any restriction of
cross-border movement would be
counterproductive if you closed borders
or say you know if you admit having been
to Italy we won't let you in suddenly
you're going to find people don't report
that they've been to Italy so it's much
better to allow people to declare
honestly what they have and then
give them as I said prudent your
practical advice with coronavirus
outbreaks around the world the NHS is
expanding testing in hospitals and
primary care centers in case it's
spreading in the UK undetected the
depart of health so the NHS was ready
for any rise in cases Thomas More Sky
News